>> [BLEEP].
I HOPE THEY DIE!
>> Sean: PRETTY DISGUSTING AND
REPULSIVE.
THE MONSTER WHO SHOT THESE TWO
OFFICER
OFFICERS STILL OUT THERE.
$100,000 REWARD FOR INFORMATION
ON THE GUNMAN.
THE SHERIFF CHALLENGED LEBRON
JAMES TO PATCH THAT REWARD.
JOINING US WITH MORE IS THE L.A.
COUNTY SHERIFF HIMSELF ALEX.
SIR, I WATCHED YOUR EMOTIONAL
PRESS CONFERENCE THE OTHER
NIGHT.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH YOUR ENTIRE TEAM AND THESE
OFFICERS IN PARTICULAR.
ANY NEW UPDATES?
THEY ARE IN STABLE CONDITION?
DO WE KNOW IF THERE WILL BE
LONG-TERM DAMAGE?
>> THAT AND THE QUESTION STILL
HAS TO BE ANSWERED.
THEY ARE STILL IN INTENSIVE
CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WILL TAKE
A WHILE TO HAVE THE RECOVERY
PROCESS AND GAIN FULL CONTROL OF
THEIR EXTRIMITIES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PRAY FOR
THEM AND SUPPORT THEM.
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL MAKE
A COMPLETE RECOVERY.
>> Sean: IN NEW YORK CITY THE
MAYOR CUT THE BUDGET BY $1
MILLION AND 150 MILLION CUT FROM
THE LAPD.
WE HAVE A VICE-PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THAT PRAISED THAT CUT
TO THE POLICE OFFICERS.
THEN WE HAVE A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THAT POLICE BECOME THE
ENEMY.
OF COURSE WE SHOULD REDIRECT
FUNDS AWAY FROM THE POLICE.
THEN WE HEARD, IN THE DNC
VIOLENCE WAS MENTIONED TWICE IN
PASSING.
HAPPENING FOR OVER 100 DAYS.
I WILL GO OVER THE LIST OF HOW
MANY OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
MURDERED.
YOUR REACTION IN TERMS OF A
LEADERSHIP POSITION AND OF TOP
POLITICIANS BASHING POLICE ON
A DAILY BASIS.
I WANT YOUR REACTION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I DON’T SUPPORT ANY ELECTED
LEADER, ANYONE WHO IS AN
INFLUENCER IN SOCIETY HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO SUPPORT LAW AND
ORDER.
I HEARD THINGS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THAT IS ASTONISHING.
THEY ARE FANNING T THE FLAMES.
POURING GAS ON THE FIRE.
THEY ARE NOT BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
THEY ARE FURTHER DIVIDING
PEOPLE.
IT’S REPREHENSIBLE.
I WON’T SAY THIS IS THE OUTCOME
OF THAT, HOWEVER THEY ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE NARRATIVE.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE ONE PERSON
IN THE CROWD THAT TAKES THEM AT
FACE VALUE.
THEY WILL TAKE INDEPENDENT
ACTION ON THAT.
PEOPLE NEEDS TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
WORDS HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THAT.
>> Sean: SHERIFF, LET ME ASK YOU
MORE DIRECTLY.
WE HAVE SEEN NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
100 PLUS DAYS, CITY AFTER CITY,
MOLATOV COCKTAILS.
PRECINCTS COMMANDEERED BY
ANARCHISTS AND COPS PELTED WITH
BRICKS AND ROCKS AND STABBED AND
SHOT.
43 OFFICERS MURDERED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY AND THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
INJURED.
ONE PARTY IN THIS COUNTRY IS
DENYING IT.
SAYING THAT’S A MYTH.
HOW DO YOU HAVE A CONVENTION AND
NOT TALK ABOUT THIS?
ONLY UNDER POLITICAL PRESSURE DO
THEY SPEAK OUT.
A LITTLE TOO LATE IF MY MIND,
SIR.
I HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR RHETORIC.
>> WELL, WE HAVAVE TO GO BY FACT
AND NOT EMOTION.
IT’S EASY TO MANIPULATE EMOTION.
IT’S HARD TO MANIPULATE FACTS.
IN NATION AVERAGE ONCE A WEEK
A COP IS KILLED IN DUTY.
ONCE A WEEK.
I KNOW THERE IS A NARRATIVE THAT
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO PUSH OUT
THERE IS A GEORGE FLOYD
HAPPENING IN EVERY DEPARTMENT
ACROSS THE NATION.
THAT’S FALSE AND IRRESPONSIBLE
AND THAT ENCOURAGES THE MOB
MENTALITY TO STORM PRECINCTS.
LAW ENFORCEMENTS AGENCY ACROSS
THE NATION NEED TO DEFEND THEIR
POLICE STATIONS AND ACT
RESPONSIBLY WITH THE PUBLIC AND
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
THE MANTRA EVERYWHERE IS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT IT GETS LOST IN THE SHUFFLE
INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
ABOUT YOUR CHALLENGE TO LEBRON
JAMES.
THERE WERE PEACEFUL PROTESTERS
CHANTING BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THAT’S THE GROUP CHANTING WHAT
DO WE WANT?
DEAD COPS?
NOW.
>> WE HAD 20,000 PROTESTORS
OUTSIDE OF MY BUILDING A FEW
MONTHS AGO EXERCISING THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT AND WE
WERE THERE TO DEFEND THEM
EXERCISING THAT RIGHT.
WHEN THEY SHOW UP ARMED LIKE
THEY ARE GOING TO PLAY NFL
FOOTBALL AS A LINEBACKER, THEY
ARE NOT A PEACEFUL PROTESTOR.
LET’S END THAT NONSENSE RIGHT
NOW.
ANYBODY WITH HELMETS AND GOGGLES
AND FROZEN WATER BOTTLES AND
MORTARS.
THEY ARE THERE TO DO DAMAGE.
WE WON’T SUPPORT THAT.
>> Sean: LET’S SEE IF LEBRON
JAMES TAKES YOUR CHALLENGE.